finalmente continuo di un gioco che ha
segnato la mia vita in negativo non so
se vi ricordate il trend out ragazzi
quel gioco dove alta vicino con
telephone non c'erano i mostri e si
scaricava telefonare morto vabbè hanno
fatto due prima di mitch ai ragazzi
volevo ringraziare lewis nash che ha
fatto le traduzioni italiano quindi
gioco di tre auto due e anche
fortunatamente in italiano partiamo
ragazzi io sono
ho lasciato tre d'autunno con la cacca
delle mutande vediamo se anche questo
sarà all'altezza se c'è stato un
improving c'è una risata
ok linda oh meno male
storia di un essere io eccola linda io
starei lì dove stai
se fossi in te cioè non sai mai che la
gente pazzo ma tra l'altro vinicolo come
finito il primo sincero l'unico quindi
questo è un tipo del primo per un'altra
roma
a piedi nudi in classe questa cosa non è
male rimini no ti prego no dai per
favore ma cosa va bè ragazzi allora
partiamo e andiamo a vedere di che si
tratta bello però il fatto che sia piedi
nudi in una scuola linda must see però
stai calmo porcava questo trovai life
sono passati a anni anni anni mi ricordo
assolutamente una sega e non mi ricordo
eravamo rimasti se c'era una trama non
mi dico niente sincero non si vedono
glass faremo in da hoffman ma che ho da
fare ogni volta mi sento uno ma
nell'altra stanza poi c'era una per
terra con la ride on line la mia sacca
come hanno potuto quello è il mio
telefono altro sul telefono perfetto
così posso usare il telefono ai ris von
un economico comune è molto più durevole
telefono con una batteria a lunga durata
grazie a dio
linda vin canale i suoi poteri
paranormali che trova i segreti e
bandire fantasmi ma sempre a piedi nudi
basta ridere porca trottola come come si
cose da fare completandole stati vita si
progredisce nella storia che è il
pianista latina il flash ok ma non è mai
detto o avesse veramente forte la
batterista del ho suonato un gatto col
telefono
va bene ok posso seguire il gatto queste
ragazze la particolarità di dren out non
so se lo ricordate per niente tube di
fantasmi attraverso il telefono perché
linda vede le cose perché ha lavorato un
sacco di volte leone cane fifone
effettivamente anche l'odore
non c'è un lucchetto anno migliore sacco
la grafica o sono io che me la sto
sognando
ecco qua fratello mi scusi lei che si
gratta la testa c'è un gatto qua è
perché li faccio una foto poi kit ago un
casino su facebook il santo iddio mese
salve posso parlare ok è poi scusi mi
dispiace linda ma chi sei buddi prof a
chiamarti buti
noi abbiamo cercato di darci di darti
una lezione per le sorti di ira shelley
donnie ayane anche miss che età ma è
accaduto qualcosa di brutto stava
impazzendo andava rinchiusa se vuoi
uscire di qui
andrea aveva la chiave ma non so dove
sia ma mi aiuto
vorrei andare a casa
e tu continuerai grattati collo per
tutto il tempo mi dai una mano no no no
no no no no
gattoni qua è scemo che palle
devo passare la mia vita seguire un
gatto va bene buche che anzi aumenta il
suo gioco e sa sempre come l'altro
abbiamo altri venti forti che vi giuro
regista o per due giorni voi ho visto
sei qua ancora che fissi l'altro basta
basta fissare quel tizio l'ho già visto
che lo fissi
zio viene da via lamaro ricchezze porca
vacca vi sono cagato sotto
ci stiamo cagando sotto e vedeva fra te
e morto è morto gatto sei tranquillo
tutto è andato il gatto è sparito ma
questa cosa non mi può dar niente
comunque ottimo
ottima esecuzione basta mi basta
miagolare alle cose basta basta fa
fatica poi per favore già è difficile
sto gioco non mi mettete un gatto che mi
faccia prendere più male del solito
questa prima è racchiusa adesso sia
aperta pur cristo santissimo 66 ma tu
vai proprio cercatele regolamento di via
probabile foto per più fatto di farci
più lo distruggo ferma svetta mi arrendo
basta la vera mente un fantasma si è
arreso per favore abbi pietà di me non
volevo seguire il ragazzo può causare
problemi ma delle vibrazioni scure mi
infastidivano scusa umana ora andro via
tipi chiara il fantasma più cagasotto
nel mondo pare comunque fantasma l'ho
fatto fuori milan e soprattutto nelle
dallo zio edili che lo sconfitto potevo
farlo anche prima inventandomi visto
fatto ma poi lo zio è andato via il
fantasma quilici che la chiave grazie
linda che la cosa andata come hai fatto
col telefono ecco 7 tutti i cagasotto
questa la chiave dell'atrio stai attenta
linda scappa per salvare la vita
ok una chiave data da andré propria
stanza dove è rinchiusa annie va bene
ciao andrea la presto
già mille views sociali streaming qual
cosa bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questo no rhymes the morning e in questo
comunque andiamo avanti
ho aperto la porta della chiave del
ladro scolastico detto ok
insomma mi facesse caricamento invece ma
proprio mentre in un'aria nuova
completamente che figata my name is line
da ed aim without delle scarpe che è
successo senza rumori ma non capisco
comunque vorrei uscire di qua se
possibile non voglio andare avanti in
posti incredibilmente pericolosi uscire
vado avanti
eccolo salve asi tu che facevi live
streaming
evitiamo di usare un ascia durante
durante questi live stream
no no no faceva foto fa ma porca [ __ ]
aiuto che male non mi ha preso la mia
preso facendo le foto poi ti denuncio
sulle prove a ya basta usare l'ascia non
sei in the forest ma che cazzo vedendo
così compare
ai lati della mappa aspettiamo di
provare
basta hai rotto le palle che oggi i
social feriscono più dell'arma bianca
possono fare quando parte può mai sulla
smetti di farmi no no stai a terra stai
a terra a terra pezzo di culo testa di
culo mi dà il telefono dio santissimo
stato tutto il fuoco funzione madotto
fuoco
io ve lo dico ora che rivelo detto come
aiuto
porca vacca
ora capitato di così non posso fare cioè
che si sta spaccando il telefono ho
versato i bio è volato via lo spettro è
volato via aia mi ha fatto anche male
testa di nicchia dove c'è già una mosca
etnica però iniziato gioco questo c'è un
bosco e giocate su piedi che per che
emergono dal 1
mi pare madonna santissima
non ho capito la mia vita quanta gente
c'è una vita
aspettare che il fantasma esca più fare
una foto al fantasma e questa cosa devo
fare
ecco era andato o santo iddio sei più
brutto del mio migliore amico ho fatto
la foto l'ho fatta 6
ho perso d'andata va battuto allagabile
nicchia sembra sembra uno di quei posti
che c'e in leone cane fifone dice giuro
che male
fatta ma voi dai loro aggiunto massa
quante potuto fare
colpito più lui che quelli in call of
duty papà ti fai una vita fantasma ma
basta nori tieni premuto giù per vedere
va bene ah ok ho gia ha già messo due
fantasmi nel catalogo sono molto
contento disfatto bello soggiorno e
quindi la zia come beh tutto aprile di
un po pallida è a posto
posso prendere lascia che secondo me vi
serve col santo iddio ha con queste robe
simboli non migliora pitto probabilmente
posso uscire soprattutto battuto è sono
forte eccoci qua sono uscito sono forte
mi scusi lo sa che la scuola infestata
lei o chi corre si sa mai
scusi tutto spaventato è effettivamente
non ha tutti i torti ci dovrebbe essere
studenti via quest'ora beh non c'è solo
satana però fa niente torna a casa
oddio face l'animazione dire che se ne
va a casa a piedi nudi tra anche lui ma
ragazzi ma delle scarpe porca [ __ ] le
scarpe pescar l'esca le scarpe e scarpe
nel mondo a piedi nudi a posto zia il
abbiamo i piedi a canon chiedo perché
sono abbastanza presto esempio sudicia
però io comunque lì la vera e vieri e
poi fai che è bravo lì non usiamo le
ciabatte sulla batteria che le metterei
le menti affamate non le ha messe mangia
il cazzo inizio particolarmente mimì
casa sta roba che in italiano e
finissima non è che impegnarmi a
tradurre ti serve è anche giorno
bellissimo anno anche taroccato il logo
della lg del modo giusta che non ho
capito dove è ambientato sul gioco 6
tipo in taiwan in vietnam
lo si capisce è comunque quelle zone
l'insano sviluppare videogiochi a quanto
pare è anche bene abbellisce della
misura entro perfetta per un gioco del
genere di me per esprimere proprio alta
pieno che cos'è questo horror
meraviglioso casa della zia
ovviamente anche ripresa cinematografica
anche bravi e quindi morta di ovviamente
il sonno sempre scalza ha camminato per
terra mandiamo scalzi sul letto quando
fini si sta chiamata 6 tempo che un
esorcista il suo nome non è male era la
sveglia questa dunque quando mi alzo la
mattina sono uguale per terra perfetto
mi fa giocare chi di giorno bellissimo
ma è sempre notti sto gioco del capo di
non riuscire a farla roba decente tipo
entra nel bagno e fare la cacca che la
mattina questa sera la prima mentre fa
pipi ti lavi anche i denti giorgia le
scarpe santo iddio
grazie grazie grazie e sviluppatori del
gioco per aver previsto delle scarpe
sulla mia protagonista i feticisti erano
già chiuso il video salve c'è una zia e
non a una scarpa glielo ruota io
sicuramente
quella carta ma nella mia presolana sono
stata io in realtà perché se vedi la
scarpa mia uguale alla tua
so che mi mancava una con il mio zaino
in prestito certo prendilo te lo regalo
si lite tra la mia scarpa è un regalo
del mio ragazzo
la scarpa c'è il tuo ragazzo delegato
una scarpata una sola data base comprato
ha detto che cambierà da ogni ragazzo
tira una scarpa tensione per avere due
scarpe devi avere due le due relazioni e
difficile comunque troviamo la scarpa
bella sarà la musica allegra non mi
piace per il tanto guarda fai come me va
in giro senza senza scarpe che secondo
me è molto più utile fidati qualunque
madonna che hanno fatto la mappa così
una donna malaga ma bellissimo lavorati
sviluppato bene sto gioco
lei sa dove una scarpa mi scusi mi
servirebbe una scarpa prova lo cascio le
strisce solo se testa ricca c sulle
strisce le strisce tv fermare omissione
di soccorso
ma non ho capito
[Musica]